yes good afternoon and thank you for
taking my call my brother for seven
years all these 220 pounds he's 5 feet 8
inches
he's got Parkinson's and cholesterol
high blood pressure diabetes and he's on
a cocktail of medications you need to
know the medication
no no just now you went through that
fast you said you got high cholesterol
you know the numbers I know he couldn't
usually when a doctor says you have high
cholesterol it translates to it's really
too low and then he said he weighs 220
and five eight five eight for guys like
the same weigh 175 pounds maybe so he's
45 50 pounds overweight he also has as a
type 2 diabetes yes and Parkinson's
disease
that's plenty plus he's a little
overweight Charmaine you there I'm here
did he have a high blood pressure yes
and he's also getting medication for his
urine to incontinence all the
medications okay so he's dribbling urine
and uncontrolled urination okay okay
Charmaine what Maria's brothers getting
all this stuff going on here what do you
think is a basic problem well I think
he's coming with almost okay when
somebody has an incontinence which means
they can't control her years ago Peter
talking and suddenly they urinate
without even any warning or walk don't
say oh my god I gotta go to the bathroom
and they turn around to look and they
pee in their pants is that usually a
bladder problem or what's causing what
can cause this journey stuff going on it
could it could be a back problem yeah
does your your brother have any
arthritis or osteoporosis or back
problems he's done yeah he walks a
little bit that bent over
but you love that fella but he does get
foxy beautiful you know yeah okay Shar
what diet would you put his brother on
okay what I would suggest two healthy
weight and then he needs to end these
anyone's to add some ultimate daily
classic and I would in some vitamin d3
and he obviously needs to get on a high
fat high like eggs and butter diet
Parkinson's
he needs to rebuild them eyelashes
trainer and how many gluco gel would he
take it
at 220 pounds oh he should take at least
15 maybe 20 so he needs it he needs at
least two bottles a month and that's
gonna support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue dysphoria rate we're a
bone making bone itself and it's one of
those things where this is a forever
thing Maria the diet getting rid of all
the bad stuff the fried foods the
process meets the oils the glutens we
brought around notes to maximize
absorption this is forever and what
would you help him do to lose that 45 50
pounds oh he can take the road yeah
throw in the Rev get in one bottle Rev
from up put a dropper full under his
tongue 30 minutes for each meal leave it
absorbs real to shoes and one bottle
will last you a month doing it three
times a day and within a few days after
starting this program this will actually
help him begin to lose a half a pound of
2 pounds a day and it's not unusual okay
to do that now the beautiful thing about
this is as long as he stays on the diet
changes as long as he stays on the
supplement program
he'll never gain the weight back that's
the magic of this program you'll never
gain the weight back and of course this
will also support healthy blood sugar
healthy maintenance repair of the
musculoskeletal system and let's see
here what
they have their mo Parkin sees how many
eggs a day should eat to support
maintance or care of brain oh boy I
would say no lesson sir six or more yeah
I like six 400 pounds of body weight so
he was 220 you really shouldn't have 12
eggs a day and you can put him in that
poquito caramel shake you can put four
or five eggs or six eggs in the morning
and do that again the evening hour do
four eggs of breakfast for he's at lunch
for a center time the key to a caramel
shake and then just use a small salad
plate or clumpy cup saucer as his meal
plates for the one meal a day he's going
to eat and it helped him lose the weight
and of course but you said the ultimate
daily classic tablets that supports
healthy blood pressure and the gluco gel
will also help him with the incontinence
too because I believe that is from a
back problem inching the nerves control
the bladder